hi everyone it's Jerry the 2004 Under 12
World Chess Championship had quite the
field of talented players
the game about to share with you is a
nice attack by the young ding therein 12
year old dingler in has the white pieces
he's rated 2231
and his opponent is 11 year old
Wesley so
who has a rating of zero still unrated
and it wouldn't be until a couple months
later he would get his first rating
eventually coming in at 21.65
. so these two players would eventually
cross that magical 2800 barrier there's
only ever been 15 players to accomplish
that feat
now if you're wondering how they
finished in the event I know I was
curious about that
dingler in finished second with nine and
a half out of 11 really a tie for first
he was beat out on tie Breaks by Zao Nan
Wesley so finished in 13th with seven
and a half out of 11 and one final note
before we dive into this game
there was another player in this field
who would also one day cross the 2800
barrier
finishing in 10th place with seven and a
half out of eleven one Fabiano caruana
okay who knows this very pairing right
here
could be the next World Chess
Championship matchup
on board with C5 this is an invitation
to a sicilian white only needs to play
E4 and there we go Sicilian Defense
this invitation is declined white goes
for a fee and Keto and an early battle
in this game over
the D4 Square
so far every black move directly or
indirectly is focused
on D4
Bishop's ready to play here soon enough
okay from here E5 another
move directed at D4 and white gets D4 in
right now before it's too late
try and do one move later Black's gonna
have too many on that
D4 Square so D4 on move 5 cdcd E4 white
hops in the center and an early pop quiz
on this move seven
I'll throw it to you as a multiple
choice everybody's a fan of multiple
choice right this guy here
he is under Fire how should you defend
it
a
B
or c
if you'd like to go ahead and pause the
video what would you come up with
okay in this game
Wesley goes with B
moves the F Pawn
considered best is Choice a to go with
the d-pawn and I imagine this is
you know one of the
points that Wesley took something away
from me from from this game as a young
player
sure in reviewing this
to play the F5 move
you know this weakens the king side
there's already One open diagonal
towards the king and now there's a
second to make this kind of a weakness
so early on probably asking for trouble
with still all pieces on board there's
only been a pawn uh one pawn exchange so
it's a very very committal move to go
with the F Pawn
whereas when you go with the d-pawn
well this guy's happy you have another
Pawn in the center
this is the more productive way to be
defending E4 right now
one other note is if you're considering
Choice C this does potentially run into
an irritating pin
it's an additional move white has
available to him right now
so D4 excuse me D5 is considered best in
this game F5
Knight C3
Bishop G7 Bishop F4
that point is now secure and Knight G to
E7
next move very nice
by white I should mention that another
this is another moment to play D5 right
here but D5 never hits
in this game Knight G to E7
and now here we go Knight to C4 a move
that would not be available to White if
this guy was already
in the center
so what is white looking to do with this
last move
this is already a critical moment in the
game this is where black goes wrong and
white is winning
for the rest of the game this is a very
high level game by the young Dean Lauren
white is eyeing up clearly this D6
Square looking to give check
now the best move in this position
is to yet again play D5 and after this
check follow-up and defend D4 like this
okay
as mentioned D5 Never Comes
black misses a really
sharp idea by white he ends up picking
up the D4 Pawn
okay there are two ways
this Pawn can be captured
if the bishop is capturing the pawn
there's going to be a serious problem
and here's how white could follow up if
the bishop captures here Knight D6 check
and then
Queen B3
and it's not so easy to stop
the queen
from getting to F7
okay it says you have to like throw a
knight
in the way give up a full piece so that
your queen could come over here to
defend big problems if you're taking
with the bishop but even here
there's still a big problem after Knight
takes on D4
Can you spot
dingler in's next move if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what's the star
move in this position
okay here we go
Bishop to H6
trying to distract this guy from
defense of the night
now in this game the Knight falls back
to E6 defending the bishop
but let's have a look at what might
happen if the bishop is captured
white would first insert this check
black is now uncasseled
and then take the Knight
and we could see these diagonals
really being an issue for the black king
what is black now going to do about
Queen takes Rook
if you move the Rook well that's already
game over
what other options might there be
Bishop here defends The Rook
and F6
but after Queen C4 how are you stopping
this
suggestion here is to take the Knight
but now after this recapture we still
see the problems on these two diagonals
what are you doing about Queen takes
Rook what are you doing about Queen F6
here's a funny line if the king scoots
over to defend the Rook
white could still take the Rook
because you would have this fork in the
end and after the Smoke Clears white is
up a rook
okay
there's some sharp continuations there
if the bishop is captured in this game
96.
Bishop takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop follows
there goes the check
and King to f8
so there were a couple moments in this
game where I thought to myself
wow that's you know the moves played by
white are showing some nice restraint
there are some tempting
moments in this game a couple tempting
moments a couple tempting moves
this is one of those moments in my
estimation
in the game Queen D2 is played what
might be a tempting move
Queen B3 threatening mate
but after Knight to E6
that defends queen of seven
mate but this Knight is not defended
when the queen is on B3 so
Queen D2
white recognizes this has a a nice
response to it Queen B3 Knight E6
so it's the simple Queen D2 keeping
things defended this Knight is secure
the queen also eyes up a weak Square H6
okay
from here A6
Queen side castles
so with this last move we're getting the
king safe we're also maybe freeing up
the queen to go elsewhere
she doesn't have to watch over
the night if there's some pressure on
the night The Rook is defending now
from here B5 and now another sharp move
here by team White
G5
trying to break down the king side
structure
so
there are a couple ways to try and sneak
into F7 that's one when the queen was on
home base
going to B3 and then F7 but here's
another path
F4 into F7
so White's trying to distract this Pawn
trying to get rid of this Pawn so Queen
F4 could hit with check
okay
follow up here is H6 which cuts out any
possibilities of Queen H6
Rook is now defending that point
From Here pawn takes Pawn
takes Pawn there's now an open line here
for a rook
this can show up
and by this point there's also
sacrifices and we see just that Bishop
takes E4 here
black does not take the bishop at this
moment at least
in the game Rook beatis played
what's happening if the bishop is
captured
the queen could go to F4 with check
let's say King here
we can have a check
here
and then Knight takes Pawn
no good answer really to Knight to F6
also there's this move right around the
corner as well
okay
so bad news if you take the bishop here
Rook B8 in this game
Rook H to G1 this is one of the benefits
of that G4
Pawn break this guy is now invited into
the party every white piece is doing
something
and completely backward development here
for team black
from here Rook H7 not a fun move to play
at all just do a real comparison or
night comparison or really in every
piece type of comparison every every
white piece is really really good right
now
Queen D4 looking to sneak into F6
hunt takes Bishop Queen F6 check
King G8
Knight D5
or just one move out from resignation in
this position right here look at the
black pieces
they are functioning on
two ranks
and the white pieces are functioning on
six
okay these are some really really scary
white Knights
how does this finish up Knight C6
that night was in a pin the Knight is
there defending one patient move I was
saying earlier
some nice restraint by white
by playing Queen D2 rather than the
tempting Queen B3
here is that last point right here the
final move of this game by white
how tempting it may be to go to F7 with
check this is of course winning as well
but white spots the very best move
final move of this game Queen G6
black resigns this square is kept open
for potentially a knight in some cases
and white is simply looking to drop the
Knight into F6 with check and take the
Rook on H7
there's no answer to this last move
black simply resigns no stopping Knight
to F6 you're gonna have to give up the
queen shortly
so very nice attacking game here by the
Young
dingler in 12 year old dingler and I
hope you enjoyed this one
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
in the comments section below
and yeah hope you enjoyed it that's all
for now take care bye